This time we have a difference of 2 cubes, and the thing that's playing the role
of the y cube down here is 125z cubed. This means, that anywhere I have y
written up here in the general form, I need to write the cube root of 125z
cubed, the cube root of 125 is 5 and the cube root of z cubed is just z so y
will be replaced by 5z. Now, instead of z cubed, which was subtracted initially,
we have 1, which means that instead of z, I'll put a 1. So again, like I said in
the question video, the z cubed up here, in this expression we're interested in,
is not at all related to the z cubed in the general expression. These are just
placeholder names. Okay, let's plug this stuff in. The thing in the form of y
minus z down here is 5z minus 1 and our trinomial is going to be 25z squared
plus 5z plus 1. Awesome. That was really great.